Four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
And we're live.
Gentlemen.
Sam Majid.
How are you?
Good.
Thanks.
Pleasure to meet you.
Pleasure Joe for coming here.
Yeah,
I'm very happy to get you guys together.
I mean that was,
I've been kind of looking at to do this
for at least two years and finally it's
arrived.
What's been your ultimate goal?
Like what was it?
Well,
he been.
Module is just a superstar that needs
more exposure.
I mean,
he's like,
like he should be running half of
civilization.
I mean he's,
he's really fantastically ethical.
You can put it in the back of a book,
isn't it?
Yeah.
But you should.
Shouldn't put that one.
Has to be in the back of the book for
sure.
Definitely not in the front.
People will read it and go,
superstar of.
I can't blow up the book we wrote
together unfortunately.
So yeah,
that is an issue to kind sam.
Thank you very generously.
Um,
are you,
are you suing the southern Poverty Law
Center?
Is that what's going on?
Yeah,
in fact,
have an update for everybody because we
crowd funded a lot of the early costs
for the case against the southern
poverty law center.
What did they do?
What does it,
what does it make that comment please?
Once upon a time,
yours truly,
a British Muslim of Pakistani origin was
listed in the United Kingdom on the
Thomson Reuters well-check database
under a category red terrorism
designation while at the same time being
listed across the Atlantic in the United
States by the southern poverty law
center as an anti Muslim extremists.
So I was both a Muslim terrorists and an
anti Muslim extremist according to two
separate lists and of course that speaks
to some of the polarization in our times
in how irrational this conversation
around extreme Islam,
Islam integration,
Muslims in the West has become.
I sued Thomson Reuters.
Well,
check the database.
This database is no joke,
it's like HSBC and and many,
many other banks use this database for
background checks on where the clients
can have a bank account with them.
So as a result of,
for example,
Thomson Reuters in their database,
Quilliam,
which is a counter extremism
organization I founded 10 years ago,
had his bank accounts shut down in the
United States because of the Thomson
Reuters wild check database system that
HSBC subscribes to.
Anyway,
we sued them.
They paid damages,
they issued an apology and they,
uh,
took my name off this terrorism
designation list they have on their well
check database module.
I think maybe you should back up further
and just give your,
kind of your short form bio in terms of,
well why would you ever be on a
terrorist watch list?
I'll do that.
Um,
but at the same time,
the southern poverty law center had
listed me,
as I said,
as an anti Muslim extremist.
So we are also,
uh,
taking legal action against them.
And um,
I,
I will get to your point,
but I think just want to say that the.
I've just held the law firm on retainer
lock and they were the ones that sued
the Rolling Stone magazine for that
college rape scandal.
Yep,
that's right.
Successfully got won that case.
Claire Lock,
which is an announcement made here
exclusively with you.
No one else knows this yet.
We have retained Claire Lock.
They are writing to the southern poverty
law center as we speak.
Um,
I think they've got wind of it,
the southern poverty law center as of I
think either yesterday or the day
before,
they've removed the entire list that's
been up there for two years.
They've removed the entire list,
which also had Ayaan Hirsi Ali on it and
it's no longer available on their
website.
Now,
is there logic that if you're a critic
of Islam,
a radical fundamentalist Islam that you
are somehow or another or racist
extremist?
So that's pretty much what they've said.
If you criticize Islam ion myself who
have come from within the community and
you've had that experience that somehow
that makes us anti Muslim,
there are a number of logical areas
involved in that logical leap that
they've made.
Do they have any distinction or is there
anything that they write that sort of
points to why they would say that?
Uh,
one of them,
honestly,
the reasons they listed,
one of them was that I had a bachelor
party in a strip club a year before I
got married.
That makes you an anti Muslim
extremists.
That was one of the reasons listed.
Oh,
nine slash 11 hijackers,
hijackers were they really listed that I
actually listed that,
which is part of the reason why we can
prove malice because what has that got
to do with anything but that doesn't.
Yeah,
that doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
So that was,
that was a primary reason.
It was one of the three main reasons
that you listed.
And another one was again,
false.
Uh,
they claimed that I had called for the
criminalization of the face veil for
Muslim women in the West,
which wasn't true.
I had called for a policy to be adopted
were in banks and airports where you're
not allowed to wear a motorcycle helmet.
You also shouldn't be allowed to cover
your face,
a face in the name of religion,
which is very different according to the
criminalization,
per se of the face veil.
That's like saying you're not allowed to
wear a motorcycle helmet and the bank.
So I believe in the criminalization of
motorcycle helmets.
It's just absurd.
It's ridiculous.
So it was a mischaracterization of my
opinion.
The artist to.
Yep.
And the other one,
uh,
the,
the reason they don't even read because
they kept changing their reasons at the
actual website has been,
um,
we've got the archive and it's been,
they've been changing it each time.
People have been pointing out the
stupidity of their allegations.
So why do they exist?
What is the southern poverty law
center's.
I mean,
this is a painful irony because if you
roll back the clock now,
you know,
20 or some odd years there reasons to
exist were great.
I mean this was the flagship
organization that was suing the KKK and
sovereign citizens and just the,
the far right white nationalists,
Christian nationalist movements in the
US and in some cases to great effect.
And their,
and their concern obviously about
extremists hate groups in the US was
totally valid.
And I mean,
it was,
it became,
I mean,
now,
now that we will see how morally
confused they are,
people who have been shining a light on
them and they,
they've,
they're this bloated organization that's
been taken way too much money and there,
I mean,
it's not,
it,
it suffers from other signs of,
of corruption or conflicts of interest.
But back in the day,
you know,
Morris dees was bringing the KKK to
court and bankrupt in their various
chapters and that,
that looked fantastic.
And now the social justice warrior moral
panic,
moral stupidity virus has gotten into
their brains and they can't
differentiate someone like Majid from a
right wing Christian,
Neo Nazi hater of Islam,
right?
Or hater of,
of,
of people from the Middle East.
Uh,
and,
and so it is with Ayaan Hirsi Ali and
have a.
now,
ironically,
you're off the website.
Now I'm on it.
I think I'm on it in a far more
transitory way.
But the article that was written about
my podcast with Charles Murray by vox
hit the southern poverty law center hate
watch page.
And so there you had articles about Neo
Nazi groups,
articles about the Austin bomber,
and then me and,
and my podcast with Charles Murray.
I definitely want to talk about that,
but I want to give people your
background first,
the reason why you were on the list in
the UK and in the first year
he's had to do with your actual
background.
So I was born and raised in Essex in the
United Kingdom.
And I came of age in what I now refer to
as the battle days of racism in the
United Kingdom.
Much has changed since then for the
good.
But in those days there were a serious,
uh,
cases of violent racism that I've faced.
A hammer attacks,
machete attacks by actual neonazis.
I mean,
I've grown up.
This is the irony of this southern
poverty law center listing.
I've grown up fighting neo Nazis on the
streets and they've been attacking me
with hammers and machetes because of the
color of my skin.
And you've got a bunch of white guys in
Alabama,
a designating me in the same breath as
they would designate,
designate these neo Nazis.
But that when I grew up in having that
experience being falsely arrested by
Essex police on a number of occasions,
profiled while the genocide in Bosnia
was unfolding against Muslims in Bosnia,
I often say to an American audience,
when I'm speaking about this,
we all now here with you on the West
Coast in this beautiful new studio you
have,
congratulations and imagine the genocide
was unfolding on the east coast against
a group of people with whom you
identified and even if it's just on a
human level,
human beings,
but you know,
even within a community identification
would impact you in a way.
For example,
if you define yourself as a Jewish and
there was a genocide against Jews on the
other side of this continent,
of this very country,
how it would impact you on,
on the west coast.
Well,
sorry over,
sorry.
Eva.
From London,
it takes us less time to fly from London
to Bosnia than it does from New York to
La.
And so it really had a profound impact
on Muslims across Europe when that
genocide was unfolding and things were
never the same again.
It radicalize an entire generation,
of course,
ideology
had a lot to do with that,
but the anger originally came from the
genocide.
So at the age of 16,
what with the domestic racism and the
situation in Bosnia unfolding as it did,
I joined his battalion,
which is a,
uh,
a non terrorist still legal in America
and in Britain and across Europe,
a Islamist organization.
It was the first of the global Islamist
organizations that aspire to resurrect
the notion of a caliphate,
a which we've subsequently seen to great
damaging effect in the form of Isis
Caliphate.
And,
uh,
the method of coming to power.
It was by infiltrating militaries in
Muslim majority countries,
uh,
recruiting army officers and then
instigating military coups,
whether that be in Turkey and Pakistan
and Egypt.
These are the countries they,
they targeted and their aim would be to
them through the military coup,
set up this caliphate,
which would then be an expansionist
caliphate.
Uh,
and we'll conquer the world.
I mean,
that's,
it sounds crazy.
That's what they believe.
And that's what they're very,
very serious and intent on bringing
about.
And now people,
when I say that,
believe me because they've seen the isis
experiment unfold,
but I joined a group that sought to do
that.
Um,
through non terroristic means are the
age of 16.
I ended,
ended up on the leadership of that
organization in the UK.
UH,
ended up co founding that group in
Pakistan in 1999 where I went,
I left the UK,
went to Pakistan,
was among the first,
the vanguard of British Pakistani
members that went out there to set the
group up.
Uh,
they've been about three or four a
cupelets in Pakistan since an army
officers had been arrested for being
members of this group and many of them
still in jail.
I spent a year in Pakistan,
went back while studying for my degree
in the University of London,
would fly Monday,
would fly on Saturdays and Sundays to
Copenhagen in Denmark.
I cofounded the Danish Pakistani chapter
of this group.
And then the third year of my degree
because I was doing law and Arabic,
uh,
resulted in me having to go to an Arab
country for the language you.
And so I chose Egypt.
And,
uh,
a day before the nine slash 11 attacks
in 2001 I ended up in Egypt.
I went to Alexandria,
enrolled in the University of Alexandria
to study for the year of Arabic
language,
which was a third year of my degree.
Um,
of course nine slash 11 happened.
And the climate changed.
The security climate change all over the
world.
Something we didn't know about nor
predicted.
And on the first of April,
2002,
my house in Alexandria was rated by the
Egyptian state security.
I was blindfolded.
My hands were tied behind my back.
I was then driven through the desert
into Cairo,
to the dungeon of the state security
headquarters in a building known as a,
as a LG has,
which is the main headquarters of an
adult.
This internal state security.
We were held in the dungeons there for
four days and they electrocuted most of
the prisoners that they had.
They're tortured them interrogate to
them.
On the fourth day,
I was taken to a prison,
known as muzzled Artora in Cairo,
put into solitary confinement for about
three and a half months.
Then charged,
eventually sentenced to five years as a
political prisoner under the Egyptian
emergency law.
Um,
and serve my full sentence there in
Egypt,
uh,
eventually left prison in 2006 and
returned to the UK.
So,
so did,
did Amnesty International gets you out
at all or they know they only can
interest in paying for my release.
Nobody got me out because that's a
finished my full prison sentence.
Um,
but what changed me and led to me to be
the man that sits before you today is,
you're right,
Sam Amnesty's adoption of me and,
and,
and a few others in the case as
prisoners of conscience.
And they took the very brave and bold
step.
Now looking back at it,
because keep in mind the context here.
This is Bush was president.
Tony Blair was prime minister and we
were in the thick of the war on terror.
We were in the middle of it and um,
I'm gonna see comes along and says we
disagree with everything this guy stands
for,
but they don't believe in using violence
to bring their caliphate about.
And so we will defend their right to say
stupid things and they shouldn't be in
prison,
they certainly shouldn't have been
tortured for it.
So I'm amnesty adopted us as prisoners
of conscience and I was 24 years old at
the time,
by the way.
So everything I've just described to you
happened to me up until the age of 24
when I was in prison.
And it was the first time in my
relatively young life from 40 now,
right.
And,
uh,
I had never been defended by any
mainstream pillar of mainstream society
in that way before.
Nobody had spoken out for me.
And that had a,
a real huge kind of emotional impact on
my psyche.
Um,
I've said in my autobiography that where
the hot leads,
the mind can follow.
And so I was now willing to consider
alternatives because of amnesties work
campaigning for me.
And so I spent the next four years in
prison,
uh,
reading,
rereading Orwell,
uh,
every one of his books,
reading Tolkien,
reading classic English literature,
studying Islamic theology,
really trying to understand the world
around me.
Um,
and I had four years to do so.
And I spent four years debating and
discussing with,
um,
pretty much the founders of Egypt's
manger,
hottest organizations who are in jail
with me in the same prison,
including the assassins or the former
president,
Anwar Sadat,
who had been killed in 1981 because of
his peace deal with Israel and his
assassins were in jail with me and
they'd been in prison longer than I've
been alive.
And so they had some collective years of
wisdom between them and most of those
jihadis,
prisoners I was in jail with,
had over the course of those years to
decades and more change their views and
reformed.
They will still conservative religious
Muslims something which I'm not.
Um,
and I never,
I don't claim to be in my,
in my work at the moment,
um,
but they were still religious Muslims,
but there were no longer a extremists
and they were no longer what I call
Islamists.
People that sought to implement their
version of Islam over society.
And so they are in four years of
constant debate and discussion with
them.
People that I knew had more wisdom than
me.
They'd been
in jail for longer than I've been alive.
I my views began slowly changing.
I read a lot of the books they wrote
about changing their own views and why
they changed and upon my release I,
I eventually a good few months after my
release,
I had to leave the organization because
I no longer believed in an ideology that
I was prepared to die for.
That is fascinating that the shift came
about in jail.
Speaking with assassin's among many
others.
Yeah.
That.
That is really incredible.
You would think that most people think
that when someone goes to jail usually
whatever criminality that they have in
them as segmented and hardened.
Yeah.
I'm.
I don't know why mine is an exceptional
case because most people,
you're right.
Whether you look at say cotto who's
known as the founding father of modern
day jihadism,
he started off like me,
a non terrorist Islamist,
but in Egypt's jails.
In fact,
the very gentle I was held in,
he was tortured and he ended up becoming
the godfather of modern day terrorism
through his book milestones or Marlin,
three in Arabic,
and yet that in my case,
for whatever reason,
I kind of went that bit further to
question everything I believed in,
but that's not normal in most cases.
When you torture people in jail,
it ends up hardening and ossifying that
ideology and people become as angry as
you know,
they become the monster that they were
seeking to defeat.
So you get out of jail,
what do you do then?
So I left the group in 2007 and by 2008
in January.
So I finished my degree.
I had one year left of my undergraduate
degree.
I graduated,
I did my masters at the London School of
Economics and political theory and while
doing the master's setup Quilliam and
Quilliam,
we,
we bill as the world's first counter
extremism organization.
It was meant to be,
we believe it is bringing us back to the
SPLC,
his allegation,
a Muslim response to extremism from
people that have lived it and been
through it.
Um,
my co founders were,
isn't mrs themselves who changed like
me,
uh,
Muslims born and raised,
come from the community to have a
community based response,
a Muslim response to this growing
problem of extremism.
And this was 10 years ago and Isis
emerged since then,
only demonstrating why this kind of
response was needed.
And so for the southern poverty law
center to designate somebody with my
background,
with that trajectory,
with somebody who was prepared to die
for this cause.
And so somebody who wanted to address
these problems as a Muslim to call for
reform for the good of my communities as
opposed to against them,
you know,
at the end of the day it can only
benefit Muslim communities of extremism
is put back in its box.
Um,
for them to then list someone like me as
an anti Muslim extremists.
It just really does shine a light on the
truth,
certainty of the situation we find
ourselves in absurdity.
And the lack of real investigation or
backing up their claims with actual
facts and information.
And that brings me to your story with
Charles Murray and vox and Ezra Klein
was linger here for a moment that it's
the same problem,
but not only is it a lack of
investigation,
but when it gets pointed out,
and I forgot the guy's name at the SPLC
who was quarterback in this,
but it wasn't more as ds,
but it was someone high up mark,
the poetic or the CEO of something coed
I think is the.
Yeah,
I thought it was mark.
Anyways,
he's listed in the.
He's named in the Atlantic article that
first put this on our radar,
but he.
They just doubled down.
I mean the,
the,
the error cannot be pointed out clearly
enough to trigger and much less than
apology,
a,
any modulation of the claim.
They just.
People just doubled down in the face of
obvious counter evidence and that's,
it's just not about a sincere engagement
with the problem.
And there's.
And there's this and there's so many
variables here that make it make it a
really toxic environment.
But one is that the,
the,
the locus of concern is never the
individual.
It is the group is the tribe and so you
can.
It's like they'll sacrifice any number
of individuals to make the political
case.
They want to make a so they don't
completely unrepentant when they're
shown to get it wrong.
And so in your case and an ions case,
it's just such a such a grievous moral
lapse because not only is it is the
attack on you illegitimate,
it actually raises your,
your security concerns and it it.
It becomes a reference point for
journalists who are confused,
who can't follow the plot or don't have
the time to,
to fact check everything.
It makes you radioactive from the point
of view of mainstream journalists
because either they go to the southern
poverty law center site to figure out
who's worth talking to and they see a
page where you're listed as a anti
Muslim extremist along with people who
bear very little resemblance to you
ideologically.
Because there's probably a few people on
there who who could be described as anti
Muslim extremists.
And here are the 10 people you don't
need to talk to about this problem,
whereas you're actually one of the most
valuable voices.
I mean objectively one of the most
valuable voices,
but probably,
you know,
I can probably count on two fingers,
anyone who would rival your voice on
this topic.
Uh,
so it's,
it's just mind boggling.
It's very difficult trying to keep this
my closest.
Yeah.
It's very difficult.
You can swing it towards.
You can tweak it to say it's very
difficult because,
um,
icon can't.
I can't fully explain to anybody what it
feels like to have lived an entire life
from roughly the age of 14 being
consumed by this issue of Muslims in the
west and this question.
And originally getting it,
answering it in one way,
and then still being consumed by the
topic,
answering it in a different way.
As I now do,
I can't describe to anybody how much
emotionally the toll that it takes to
have your whole life have defined your
whole life by trying to answer this
question and because you for it.
Because
this is a question that concerns you
when I joined these limits group,
I did.
I was wrong and adopted some really
nefarious ideas,
but did so because I gave a damn and
cared for a genocide that I saw
unfolding and desperately wanted a
solution.
So even when I became an Islamist,
I did so out of care and love and
concern for what I believed was my
community under attack.
So to have a bunch of people come along
and say that I am anti the very
community that I've believer of.
I have fought for all my life,
you know,
and have and my life has been consumed
and defined by this.
It really is taking the one thing away
from somebody that they have.
I mean,
I went to jail for this thing.
I have people have died in front of my
eyes from the torture wounds in prison
because of this thing.
To have someone completely ignorant in
that way,
to,
to deprive me of having the,
of being able to claim that I have stood
for my community.
But by instead saying that I'm anti that
community,
it really does kind of make you feel
like crap.
Jo,
when did this start happening?
This moral panic that you've constantly
discussed in these flippant sort of
accusations without real.
Any real solid objective reasoning
behind calling someone like you or Ion
Hirsi Ali,
who's the victim of female genital
mutilation to say that she's an anti
Muslim,
that she's Islamophobic is.
It seems to me it's almost insane,
but it seems to me to be prevalent.
This is something that is a common
sentiment today that I don't recall ever
seeing anything like this one or two
decades ago.
Yeah.
We might have a better sense than I do,
but I don't.
It's become increasingly salient to me
just because I've been doing this work
for better or worse and colliding with
these people more and more.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's definitely an export from some
trends in intellectual life that go back
50 years or more.
I mean,
they always,
oh,
what postmodernism did,
and I mean,
you can go back further than that.
It's just there.
There's a,
there's a,
a framework,
a kind of pseudo intellectual framework
where facts can't be talked about as
facts.
They're,
they're intrinsically political.
They intrinsically convey power
disparities.
Um,
you know,
science is just a tool of power sort of
thinking,
and this goes back a ways,
but it is,
it's now seemingly ascendant on the left
in a way that is,
is just fairly bewildering amount.
It seems to be only two subjects.
Gender and race.
Those are the ones that get.
Those are the big ones.
I think it's,
I'm sure we could find more if we take a
minute to think about it,
but there are,
those are,
those certainly dwarf every other.
Those are the ones where there's a wall,
there's a wall that you can't get
through with reason
that this isn't quite raised.
This is the way it's drawn.
A lot of energy from concerns about
racism.
Identity.
It is.
The perception is that Muslims are a
politically beleaguered minority that
have to be.
So it is like,
it is a great.
I mean people think there's,
you know,
it's racist to criticize Islam.
Has that made any sense?
I mean,
you know,
Ben Affleck being one,
but it is,
you know,
this is their minority in Los Angeles.
They're not a minute.
The second biggest religion on earth
this is we're talking about one point 7
billion people in there and the
criticism of Muslim extremism for the
most part is focused on societies where
you have most cases,
a majority Muslim population,
you have women and gays and,
and freethinkers treated terribly.
And that's,
that.
That is the,
you know,
the center of the Bullseye in terms of,
what,
what one is criticizing when one talks
about the accuracy.
So I,
that there was a lot of this stuff.
There's some,
this paranoia,
this son of a irrational approach,
this conversation that Sam suffered from
and when,
when,
when I first met him,
uh,
I Miss New York at the intelligence
squared debate that heat that.
So Ayaan Hirsi Ali and Douglas Murray,
who I believe you've had.
Yes.
On this podcast,
we're on one side of a debate.
I was on the other side of this debate
and the motion that we were debating was
Islam is a religion of peace.
I was back then arguing,
well,
half of my true belief is because I
actually don't believe it's a religion
of peace or war,
it's just a religion that is interpreted
in different ways,
but I had to pick a side and so I picked
that side in defending the motion and an
a on an will on the other side.
And there was a,
there was a dinner afterwards for the
speakers and Sam was there.
And imagine you were there as a guest.
Yeah.
Um,
and so it's my,
well,
I didn't know who he was at a,
on an I were locked in conversation,
post debate conversation and uh,
uh,
ion invited Samhsa to have his say and
she said,
I want to hear what Sam Harris has to
say.
And so
context is relevant.
So we're at.
So we had a public,
he's seen these intelligence squared
debates that are there,
very well produced online.
I don't know that they're televised
anymore,
but they're online.
They're,
they get a great theater in Manhattan
and you know,
as an audience,
maybe a thousand people and,
and John Donvan the journalist is the
impresario.
And,
but then this was a dinner afterwards,
were the organizers and the participants
been there,
there may be 70 people in the back room
of a restaurant and Majid Nih,
we're not at the same table,
thankfully we were like 50 feet away
from each other but facing each other.
And so he was at the table with ion and
the other speakers and at one point that
everyone's getting debriefed about how
this went.
And Ion says why a Sam Harris is here.
I'd like to hear what he has to say
about the debate.
And so I look at my budget and he's
okay.
He's either at least 50 feet away from
me and I'm a.
I mean,
do you want me to say what I,
you?
So I would say so he had made moves in
this debate that I considered
intellectually dishonest.
And,
and I mean,
he,
he's,
he's playing a game and this is not a
real conversation.
This is a formal academic style of
debate where his job is not to leave his
view open to influenced by the other
discussions.
He's,
he's making a case.
Um,
uh,
and I didn't know it at the time,
but he felt unnaturally constrained by
the format of the debate.
He had to argue that Islam is a religion
of peace and some of the moves he made
there I thought were dishonest.
And so I said,
I'm a mom and I remember this more or
less verbatim because we talked about,
and we've since transcribe it into a
book,
but,
um,
I said,
Majid know everyone in this room
recognizes that you have the hardest job
in the world and we're all very glad
that you're doing it.
You have to somehow convince the next
generation of Muslims that Islam really
is a religion of peace and the jihad is
just an inner spiritual struggle and
that it'd be martyrs don't get 72
virgins in paradise and all the rest.
And so my question for you is,
is this,
do you really believe that,
that this is the case now?
Or do you,
do you think that pretending that is
the,
that is the case,
is the method by which you will make it
the case that if you just pretend long
enough and hard enough,
it'll become so
and the extra line here was.
And can you just be honest with us in
the privacy of my final sentence was,
and you know,
we're not on,
we're not televised now,
can you just be honest with us here?
And uh,
so,
so I responded immediately and said,
are you calling me a liar?
And
Seventy we now 70 people and I'm like
into my second gin and tonic and,
and he's given me the sort of Middle
Eastern stare down across.
You repeat today said,
no,
I'm asking you just hear that where
there's no cameras,
can you just be honest with us?
And I said,
are you calling me a liar?
And it didn't go too well at all.
The entire,
everyone on the table kind of went quiet
and I didn't know who this guy was.
I never met him and I should have known
who he was.
And then I think somebody are very
tactfully changed the conversation and
just completely veered off this.
And I'd never,
I never spoke to them again for another,
what was it,
a couple of three years we'd never
crossed paths in San.
And the reason I bring this up is that I
was one of those guys that didn't want
to entertain a conversation with Sam,
uh,
based upon the defensiveness when it
came to this topic.
And I think that actually it's important
to say that to people that because you
asked him a question about the Charles
Murray situation,
a lot of people,
rather than actually wanting to engage
with someone on the substance of their
ideas,
that I think in the climate we're in
today,
they're engaging with people based upon
their,
on their feelings.
And those feelings are valid.
Of course everyone has the right to
their feelings.
But we've got to try as hard as we to
detach
those feelings from because that's
clearly not what the principle of
charity means.
You lend the person that you're speaking
to the best possible interpretation of
what they're saying and,
and,
and allow them to clarify what they mean
as opposed to you putting into their
mouths what,
what they mean,
and telling them what they mean.
I learned that,
you know,
because then two years later he reaches
out to me and he says,
I think we can try again.
Are you willing to have a conversation
with me?
And,
and I hadn't originally remembered it
was the same guy,
so that's fine.
I got my foot in the door just because
you didn't know who I was.
And then we had this conversation,
which,
it's a lesson for me because we had this
conversation.
It's,
it's,
it's called Islam in the future of
tolerance.
It's become a book right?
Published by Harvard University Press.
We had this conversation that became a
book that been made into a film,
which I think any couple of weeks now we
hear some news on that.
It's coming up with that.
So we did a lecture tour of Australia
and the people who organize that,
she made a documentary that we realize
this lesson to your question and that is
that I am somebody that didn't engage
with him on the substance of his
question,
but actually fired a misfire and
emotional misfire on,
on,
on what was really questioning his
motives for asking the question rather
than actually addressing,
addressing the points he was making.
And I think that when I,
because I didn't remember who he was,
I then started the conflict conversation
in new,
uh,
without the memory of my original
judgment on him and the conversation
went really well.
So we've got to somehow be able to
divorce ourselves from that background.
That can happen.
I mean,
it can be done.
It's just,
it takes people have strong character to
try to like abandon all preconceived
notions from the past conversation.
Just start fresh.
Yeah.
I unfortunately,
this example of,
of a kind of a signal success has,
has caused me to,
in the end kind of miss band a lot of
energies.
There's assuming that trying to
replicate it.
I keep thinking I keep walking into
another situation and thinking this is
possible.
Is that why you deleted twitter?
Well,
I,
yeah,
yes.
Um,
so you haven't deleted your account?
I'm still on twitter,
but I,
I will,
uh,
based on this reason episode,
I use it.
They're fascinated by people and their
struggles with social media with like
detaching from it,
reattaching from it,
getting addicted to it.
I mean I know so many people that will
look at their twitter at like 1:00
in the morning before they go to bed and
something pisses them off and then they
can't sleep really common.
I was not,
I don't consider myself someone who had
a,
a real pathology with that amount was,
you know,
I have,
I dunno,
6,000
tweets or 7,000
tweets over the course of many years,
so I'm not,
I was not tweeting that much.
I was not even looking that much.
I was,
I was fairly disengaged and I've never
used facebook as a.
I've never,
I just use.
Facebook is kind of a publishing
channel.
I never engaged with comments,
but I was looking
enough and it,
it was one,
it was clearly making me a worse person.
I mean,
I just,
it,
I was,
I was reacting to stuff that I didn't
need to react to and it was amplified in
certain criticisms and voices which need
not have been amplified.
And in this,
in this last case,
it just turned a create a huge explosion
in my life.
I was in the middle of a vacation,
which I basically torpedoed because of
what I saw on twitter and it was just,
it was like the perfect infomercial for
why you don't want to be engaged with
your vacation.
How while.
So I'm in the middle of the first
vacation I've taken with my family for a
very long time.
It was at least a year and wow.
And so,
you know,
we're on Hawaii and just like I'm
supposed to put everything down to be
the best father and husband I can be.
Right.
And that was my intention.
That's what was happening.
Uh,
it happened for a good solid 24 hours
and then I pick up my phone and I see
that that raises salon and Glenn
Greenwald and Ezra Klein had all
attacked me in the space of an hour just
like now it's,
this goes out to millions of people.
He was also was asking about the Charles
Murray thing.
Yeah.
Well,
truth is,
I can't even see what I,
I didn't look at what Greenwald had
done.
Um,
he was circulating.
Somebody is video about me,
how I'm,
I think I'm a racist in that video.
Reza Aslan blocks me,
so I can't even see what if he attacks
me by name,
but he blocks me so the hay,
so I can't even see what his export.
But uh,
so I,
but I just saw the aftermath of that,
you know,
lots of stuff.
Lots of notifications coming to me with
both of us tagged.
And then Ezra published this.
I suppose I should back up a however
painful way to describe what happened
here.
But.
So I had Charles Murray on my podcast a
year ago and Charles Murray's this,
this a social scientist who published
the bell curve back in the nineties,
which was a book about Iq and,
and success in,
in western societies like our own.
And uh,
uh,
it's a book where he worries a lot about
the cognitive stratification of society.
We have a society that is selecting more
and more for a narrow band of talents
that are fairly well captured by what we
call Iq.
And there is a kind of winner take all
situation where people are really,
you know,
500 years ago,
if you had a,
a very high Iq and you're,
you're just pushing a plow next to your
neighbor.
You had no real advantage.
But now you can start a hedge fund or
you can start a software company.
And we're,
we're seeing this real shocking
disparity.
And in a good fortune,
really.
Uh,
so,
uh,
he wrote this book,
it had a chapter on race which talked
about the disparities in,
in racial groups,
statistically observed disparities.
And,
uh,
the claim about the source of those
disparities was by even the standards of
the time,
but certainly the standards of today and
incredibly tepid mealy mouthed,
just hand waving.
It was not this,
you know,
here comes the Third Reich Declaration
of,
of white supremacy.
It was undoubtedly,
there are environmental engineers,
etic reasons for this and we don't
understand them,
you know,
it was just like,
to think that is one or the other.
We're not in a position to know what the
mix is of,
of,
of influences now.
Um,
and that is a virtually any honest
scientists take on the matter.
Um,
and certainly today,
I mean,
it's only become more so,
uh,
but that went off like a nuclear bomb.
I mean,
that was just,
that was such a,
um,
uh,
I mean it's,
it's the most,
um,
so,
and at the time I never read the book,
I just thought this had to be.
That's cool.
It would be vilified for,
for that obs and he,
he's been vilified ever since then,
ever since I've ignored him.
He need deep platformed and assaulted
recently.
So that's what happened.
So,
so he went to Middlebury to give a talk,
you know,
20 some odd years,
25 years after he wrote this book.
Oh,
by the way,
he's also listed by the southern poverty
law center and so that,
that that's what contributed to the d
platforming and the violent protest
against him at Middlebury.
What's crazy is the whole thing is a
propaganda for the superiority of the
Asian race and everyone's going to say
that they,
we'll talk about white supremacy and far
and above.
I mean,
that's basically what his book proved
and you know,
they're suing Harvard now there's a
group of Asian students that are suing
Harvard because they're discriminated
against because they're required to have
higher scores because they're assumed to
be smarter.
So the standards for Asian students
entering into Harvard is higher than
white people.
Wow.
Yes.
Well,
Asian privilege has a big problem.
Yeah.
Your grandfather was working on the
railroads in California as an indentured
servant and all by privileged trickled
down.
There's obviously a lot of factors that
lead to icu to,
to hire cute,
but to ignore what those are,
to ignore it completely to ideology.
Yes,
exactly.
Only ideology and this idea that you
cannot look at statistics,
you cannot look at facts and in your
conversation with Ezra Charles,
that sort of or as reclined rather.
That's what I got is that this is,
this is an ideological issue and that
you,
it's almost like an impossible subject
to breach,
like you can't even discuss the fact
that certain races demonstrate low Iq
and then let's look at what could be the
cost of those even discussing that
somehow or another is so inherently
racist that it must be ignored or it
must be silenced and that you must first
concentrate on all the various
injustices that have been done to those
people who have this lower Iq.
Yeah.
Well let me just take a couple minutes
to close
the various doors.
Take owl that are now a jar based on
what we've said on your holiday and you
get so.
So we'll just take a little more
context.
So yeah,
as you said,
Charles Murray went to Middlebury
College and was d platform and he was
not only the platform,
so the usual the platform and with the
students turning their back to the
speaker and shouting and not let
anything happen,
but the professor who invited him,
who is a liberal professor who wanted to
essentially debate him,
he wants to act when they're leaving the
hall,
they both get physically attacked by a,
a crowd of students.
Charles was,
was not hurt.
His host,
a female professor got a concussion and
a neck injury that,
that still persist and this now more
than a year later.
So I was like,
Shit that she was actually a registered
Democrat by this.
No doubt.
And,
and they're driving out in an suv where
that gets,
I mean someone pulls a stop sign out of
the sidewalk and I still got the
concrete ball on the end of it and this
suv gets smashed with this concrete laid
and stop sign.
I mean this was,
this is happening at one of the most
liberal privileged colleges on earth.
It's nuts.
So anyway,
that was the thing that put Marie on my
radar after all these many years of my
ignoring him and I had actually I felt
guilty because I had declined to be a
part of at least one project because his
name was attached,
right?
Because I just thought that this guy is
radioactive.
He's,
he's got some white supremacist agenda.
I had believed the,
the,
the lies about him.
Uh,
and then I saw this and I thought,
okay,
well maybe he is the canary in the coal
mine or,
or certainly one of the canaries in the
coal mine that I had ignored where the,
as you say,
there's certain topics are considered so
politically fraught that you cannot
discuss them no matter what is true.
Like this is like,
it's just a,
you know,
there has to be a firewall between your
conversation about reality and these
sorts of facts.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
he said he's been suffering from having
transgress that boundary.
And so I had him on the,
on the podcast a being fairly agnostic
about his,
his actual social policy commitments and
his political concerns.
And just wanting to talk about,
uh,
you know,
the facts and so far as we touch them
lightly,
they had zero interest in intelligence,
a as measured by Iq a,
although it's an interesting subject,
but I hadn't,
you know,
hadn't spent much time focused on that
and I had a truly zero interest in
establishing differences between
populations with respect to intelligence
or anything else.
But I see what's coming.
I see the fact that,
that the more we understand ourselves
genetically and environmentally,
the more we will if we go looking or
even if we're not looking,
we will discover differences between
groups.
And the end game for us as a species is
not to deny that those differences exist
or could possibly exist.
It's too deny that they have real
political implication.
I mean with the,
the political employ,
the political framework we need is a
commitment to,
to equality across the board and a
commitment to treating individuals as
individuals.
There's nobody who's the average of a
population is meaningless with respect
to you.
And that will always be so and I'm and
whatever,
you know,
whatever diversity of talents there is
statistically in various populations,
we want societies that simply don't care
politically about that.
I mean that's just,
it's just not what it's our political
tolerance of one another and supportive
of one another is not predicated on
denying individual differences or even
statistical differences across groups.
It can't be because we know that there
are people walking around like a,
you know,
Elon musk who gets out of bed every
morning and does the work of like 4,000
people.
Right?
And people who just are struggling to
work at starbucks and hold down a job.
And our political system,
we don't say one person is more valuable
politically and socially than another,
even though one person is capable of
doing massive things that,
that,
uh,
many,
most other people aren't.
It's when it comes time to,
to write laws and create institutions
that protect that,
that support human flourishing.
We,
we have to engineer times that raise all
the boats.
And so,
you know,
and,
and you know,
they're legitimate debates about the
social policies that will do that and
they're legitimate debates about facts
so we can debate scientific fact and,
and you know,
the,
the results of,
you know,
psychometric testing or,
or behavioral genetics that are relevant
to this question of intelligence,
uh,
and we have a good faith debate about
the data.
And then we can have a good faith debate
about social policy that should follow
from the data.
But what's happening on the left now is
on either at either of those two tiers
of conversation,
there are just straight up allegations
of,
of racism that hits you the moment you
touch certain certain.
Yeah.
Can I say that?
The,
that,
what he's just summarize that.
And what I've heard sounds to me as
being more humane than the implications
of the argument that the left who were
opposing will.
Sam has just said,
oh,
because if you think about it,
the implications of their argument would
be there.
They want to deny the facts because
they're scared that those facts
word
from which there would be derived a
policy that would reflect those facts
and otherwise in their minds they are
marrying those two.
They are marrying the notion that if in
statistical observance there are
variances in Iq between groups
in their minds that means the policy
should follow from that,
so it's why they're resisting what he
saying.
Whereas what he's saying is there is no
connection between what the policy
should be and what the facts may be
because of the kind of world we want to
live in,
a should aspire to equality regardless
of what the science is saying,
because one is policy and one is
science.
I freely agree with you on that,
but I don't think that's necessarily
exactly what they're saying.
Well,
I think what they're saying is,
and what they're doing is they almost
feel so guilty that any discussion
whatsoever about race can't be held
unless you repeatedly bring up all the
instances of racism and suppression that
indiscrimination that that group has
suffered from.
It's like you can't.
It doesn't exist as a statistic island.
You have to bring everything in together
if you don't do that,
that's where their protest comes from
and I think that was one of the things
that I got from your conversation with
another client,
wasn't willing to just discuss what's
the implication of these issues and
completely dismissed this.
This fact that Asian people score far
better.
There is not a.
there's not a place for that by,
by conceding on the data.
It's almost as if they fear that the
implication must necessarily follow that
the policy will also be supremacist in
that way.
I wonder.
I honestly think what we talked about
before is a big part of it is
ideological idea sport and that they're
just volleying back.
I don't think they're willing to take.
I think one of the real strengths of
character that you demonstrate in a
debate or any discussion of facts is
when uncomfortable truths rear their
ugly head that are counter to your,
uh,
your personal position.
You have to be able to go.
You got a really good point.
You've got a good point.
There's something to that.
I see what you're saying.
Okay.
This is what my concern would be into.
This would be a rational,
real conversation.
This is what I would worry about,
and then you would I'm sure say
absolutely.
I would worry about that as well,
and then you would have this sort of a
discussion.
I didn't get that from that conversation
you had.
I got ping pong,
I got blah,
blah,
blah.
I got this rallying back and forth of
ideas rather than two human beings not
digging their heels into the sand.
Just trying to look at the ideas and
look at the statistics and look at these
studies for what they are and look at
Charles Murray and what he's gone
through and should we be able to examine
these statistical anomalies should be
able to examine athletic superiority.
Should we be able to examine a
superiority that a Asians show in
mathematics and a lot of the sciences,
should we.
Should we be able to or should we just
dig our heads in this?
Should we just let things sort
themselves out and quietly ignore all
the reality?
Yeah.
I don't know why,
so I should say that I am,
I certainly understand people's fear
that if you,
that anyone who would go looking for
racial difference is very likely
motivated,
motivated by something unethical or
unsavory.
Right.
So like,
like you could imagine,
you know,
white supremacists being being super
enamored of this
possibility that these data says yes and
they all.
Yes.
And so they look at the Asian
statistics.
Uh,
so,
so that's,
I get that right.
And there is some things that,
and this was the question I had for
Charles Murray on,
on that podcast,
I said like,
why pay attention to any of this?
What is the upside in the,
in the infinity of,
of interesting problems we can tackle
scientifically.
Why focus on population differences?
And you know,
frankly,
I didn't get a great answer from him and
his answer his answer,
his answer is,
well,
I think the best version of his answer,
which I agree with,
but still it may not justify certain
certain uses of attention.
It's just that if you,
there's this massive bias that I'm
basically,
we're all working with a blank slate
genetically,
and therefore any difference you see
among people is a matter of,
of environment.
And so,
so then you have people have privileged
environments and people who have
environments that,
that,
um,
uh,
where they're massively under resourced.
And so therefore any different
representation at the,
you know,
the higher echelons of success and
achievement and power in our society.
Uh,
you know,
if there's 13 percent African Americans
in theU ,
s if you look at the top doctors in
hospitals or the top academics or the,
um,
you know,
the Oscar winners or wherever,
wherever you want to look for,
for,
for achievement.
If there are less than 13 percent
African Americans in any one of those
bins,
that has to be the result of racism or
systemic racism.
That is the left,
the left word bias at this moment.
And so it is with Jews for antisemitism.
So it is for women.
Um,
you know,
there should be an equal representation
of women in computer,
software engineers at Google,
at any lack of any disparity.
There must be the result of either a
just inequitable resources for kids in
schools or,
or somewhere along the way or I'm kind
of a selection pressure from the top
that,
you know,
we,
we don't like women in,
at Google or blacks at the Oscars.
And so that's the.
So Marie's concern is if you believe
that,
and I'm not exactly what he said,
but this is,
this is what I believe he thinks,
but I could be putting some words into
his mouth here,
but this is certainly what many other
people on his side of the debate thing,
if you believe that you will,
can consistently find racial bias and
antisemitism and mysogeny where it
doesn't exist.
Right?
So like if you,
if you go look,
if you go to a hospital and the,
and this is a real problem there,
like,
like you know,
the academic departments in the medical
schools at the best medical schools are
under massive pressure to find like real
diversity in representation at the
highest level you need to find a ta head
of cardiology,
his black right.
Um,
and if you and you and the fact that you
haven't done that is a sign that there's
a problem with you and your organization
and your process of hiring.
Now,
if it's just the case for whatever
reason,
that there are not many candidates
likely have less than 13 percent for
that field or to take the,
you know,
the James Damore memo memo at Google,
right?
If it just is the case that women forget
about this,
is that this was beyond aptitude.
This just goes to interest.
If it's the case that women,
for whatever reason,
genetic and or environmental are less
interested in being software engineers
on average than men are than you then
having 20 percent women's coding
software at Google is not the price.
It's not Google's problem,
it's just the fact that this is the
popular,
what the population interests are.
Now we should no doubt racism still
exists,
no doubt misogyny and sexism still
exists there.
There are,
I mean there's proof of this to be found
as well,
but if to assume an absolute uniformity
of human,
of interest and aptitude in every
population you could look at is just
scientifically irrational.
That would be a miracle
that were the case.
So at this stage allow me to remind
everybody that was sam summarizing what
he thinks Charles Murray was saying as
opposed to Sam w.
no,
nope,
no.
My final point is it's just a true
point.
Their jeans,
almost everything we care about are
massively influenced by genes.
Not One hundred percent to you though is
that people have taken your summaries of
other people's stuff,
but that wasn't even necessarily Charles
Murray's position.
Your.
It's your summary of his position in
relationship to this.
This fight against that.
The thing that I would add and the thing
where there's some daylight between the
two of us,
me and him
on my podcast is this is so toxic to be
trafficking in population differences
with respect to icu,
that and it's not,
it's not absolutely clear what social
policies turn on really nailing down
these differences.
I mean,
so you could go want me to take it even
more toxic as an example.
Perhaps it's like you could decide,
uh,
you know,
the Roma in Europe that the Gypsies like
this is like a very isolated,
beleaguered community.
Who knows how in bread it is.
Um,
I don't know.
It's just this is a,
this is an outlier community.
Like anyone who's going to want to do
massive Iq testing on the Roma.
What's the,
what's the point of doing that?
Right?
Like,
you know,
like it seems like a,
just a,
a kind of political time bomb to devote
resources in that way because we know
that the policy you want whatever new,
whatever this,
the main ICU is of any group,
the policy you want is to give everyone
whatever opportunities they can avail
themselves of.
So we want,
we want people to have the best schools
they can use and then we'll find people
who need to be in,
in more remedial schools for whatever
reason,
or you know,
people like,
you know,
the one population that has 10 times the
amount of dyslexia than another
population say,
and they'll be undoubtedly genetic
reasons for that,
you know,
there may be environmental reasons for
that as well,
but there's,
we need to be able to cater to all of
those needs with just this fundamental
commitment to goodwill and equality
without being panicked that we'll find
stuff that just blows everything up.
But on the left there,
there's the sense that the only way to
move forward toward equality is to lie
about what is scientifically pause,
plausible and demonize anyone who won't
lie with you.
That's the ideological point that this
is a new thing though,
right?
I mean,
relatively speaking,
this,
uh,
this hard nose stance from the left of
the equality of outcome.
And,
and the only reason why there wouldn't
be 50 percent women or 50 percent black,
50 percent in it.
You just pick any marginalized group.
The only reason why it wouldn't be even
across the board with all other races is
because of discrimination.
This is a fairly new stance.
So I mean,
there were,
there were moments that were fairly well
publicized that I don't forget when
Larry Summers got fired from Harvard,
so Larry Summers was the president of
Harvard and he's a famous economist and
he gave a speech for which she was
fired.
Uh,
there might be a little more color as to
why he was fired.
He was fired because he,
he wants the wheels started to come off.
He didn't,
he had alienated enough people that he
didn't have friends to kind of prop him
up.
But,
but the thing that pulled the wheels off
was that he gave a speech and he said,
we know there are,
are differences in,
in the bell curves that describing a
mathematical aptitude between men and
women.
And this explains why there are many
more top flight male mathematicians and
engineers than women.
And it's not that they even,
it's not that the,
uh,
the means of the,
the,
of the bell curves are different.
So the,
the means could be the same,
but there could be more variant so that
the tails are thicker in the case of,
of the mail,
but bulk herbs,
so at the,
at the absolute ends,
both the,
the low end and high end,
you have many more people.
So you know,
if you're,
if you're going to ask you what's the in
the same size population,
how many people do you have at the 99
point nine,
nine,
nine percentile of aptitude in math.
Say it could be that you have and
there's,
there's a fair amount of data to show
this many more men at the tails than
women.
Right?
And,
and that's true for grandmasters in
chess,
right?
It's just this is not a,
a,
and it may be true for something like,
you know,
playing pool,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're just differences and that may
not be entirely environmental.
Almost certainly are not entirely
environmental.
Uh,
that is one,
right?
It's a big issue in the world of pool
men and women play separately and
there's no reason physically why they
shouldn't.
Yeah,
they're not,
it's not a strength game,
but women are allowed to play in men's
tournaments,
but they never.
When Jean Baluchis was a woman who was
a,
she was like one of the only women ever
compete and beat men.
She's like an extreme outlier and this
was like,
I want to say it was in the late
seventies and eighties.
And other than that there's been a few
women that have done well in
tournaments,
but when they come to Major League
professional pool tournaments,
they're almost always one by men.
Um,
and um,
when I say almost,
I mean like 99 point nine percent.
So there was a,
a Commonwealth Games have been happening
as we,
it was just over the last couple of
weeks and there was a male to female
transgender athlete in the weight
lifting category.
That's a whole nother ball.
Participated in the women's competition
and the Commonwealth Games at the time
of her joining hadn't yet put down a
rule asked to testosterone levels in
females competing.
And so this male to female transgender
person qualified in the female games and
was as you'd expect,
I'm winning in all of the Games and was
the front runner and destined to win the
competition as a male to female
transgender person and the only reason
and it would have led to a huge crisis
in the Commonwealth Games because there
was some resistance to this notion.
I'm out.
Of course,
the questions that arise is this fat men
will naturally with higher levels of
testosterone.
For example.
The only reason it didn't lead to the
crunch time and that was a huge scandal
of,
of winning is that she injured herself
in the competition and by sheer
accident.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I can expand on that a little bit
because I've actually gone through this
extensively because there was a woman
who was used to be a man,
was competing in mixed martial arts
against women and just beating the shit
out of them.
And I was saying that this is,
this is a mistake and that you're.
You're looking at whether someone should
be legally able to identify as a woman
portray themselves.
A woman,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Do you have the freedom to become a
woman in quotes?
In our society?
Yes,
but you can't deny biological nature and
there's physiological advantages to the
male frame.
There's specifically when it comes to
combat sports,
that's my wheelhouse.
I'm an expert.
I understand there's a giant difference
between the amount of power that a man
and a woman can generate and if you're
telling me that a guy living 30 years of
his life as a man that's,
that's essentially like a woman being on
steroids for 30 years.
Then getting off and
then having regular women being forced
to compete with her and try to pretend
this a level playing field.
It is not.
There's a difference in the shape of the
hips,
the size of the shoulder,
the density of the bones,
the size of the fists.
That's a giant factor in your ability to
generate power is the size of your
fists.
It's also an ethical problem and it's
not just competition.
Here is he have girls getting beaten up
by someone who used to be a man.
Yes,
but people came down on me harder than
anything that I've ever stood up for in
my life,
never in my life do I think there's
going to be a situation where I said,
hey,
I don't think that guy should be able to
get his penis removed and beat the shit
out of women,
and then people like you're out of line,
but that's the summary of this.
That's literally what happened.
This is a conversation that I had with a
woman online as well during this whole
thing.
She said she,
this person who had turned into a woman
has always been a woman and I said,
but she was a man for 30 years.
She goes,
no,
she's always been a woman.
I go,
even when she had sex with a woman and
fathered a kid and she says,
yes.
Even then I go,
well,
we're done because you're just talking
nonsense.
This is ideology,
ideology cover exact.
The front says they are just that.
She had a male physique.
This person who was arguing with me
wants to claim this moral high ground of
being the most progressive and they're
always looking to step on top of anybody
who's less progressive than than and
complaint and proclaim superiority,
and this is the ideological sport.
This is the idea sport that you see with
what people are playing.
Ping Pong with our ideas and not
listening you.
You need to listen to experts in when
you're.
Especially when you're talk about
martial arts,
there's a the the.
The difference is so profound and the
results are so critical because you're
talking about a sport where the
objective goal,
the goal is clear.
It's very clear.
Beat the fuck out of the other person in
front of you,
so anything that would give you an
advantage in beating the fuck out of
that person should be really looked at
very carefully and not thrown through
the lens of this progressive ideological
filter that we're going through right
now because that's what it is.
I mean that's how people are looking at
it and it's with weightlifting as well.
When transgendered athletes going to
weightlifting competitions,
the male to female transgender athletes
are overwhelmingly dominant.
I mean,
is this,
is this a coincidence or it's.
No,
it's someone who had fucking
testosterone pumping through their
system and n and a y chromosome their
whole life and now all of a sudden we're
supposed to say no.
She's a woman.
She's a.
she's dainty.
She's got size 14 feet.
She's got gorilla hands.
Like what in the fuck are we doing?
So,
so I think as you said earlier,
it's she is a woman,
but for the purposes of competition
against other women,
you know,
legally she's a woman at that stage.
She goes through that identity
transition,
but I think we have to recognize it.
I think even many traditional feminists,
I'm making this point much to the angle
of the Trans community.
They're hold on you.
What you're doing in this way is
actually we fought so hard and so long
for these female spaces where we have a
space of our own and that's people that
used to be men are coming into those
spaces is actually quite literally
beating the crap out of us spaces.
Whether it's in boxing,
whether it's in weight lifting and
martial arts,
they are,
by definition they dominating or this of
course they offer what the reasons
you've said experts that they're calling
upon or almost all transitioned doctors,
surgeons or people that have
transitioned themselves when they speak
to actual board certified
endocrinologist and some of the only do
it off record,
but one of 'em forget her name.
She was in one of the big mixed martial
arts publications.
Ramona crushed sec,
I believe is her name.
She's saying,
no,
not only does it it it actually doing
this transition like from male to
female,
you're forcing your.
You're putting estrogen into the system,
so the bone density change that would
ordinarily take place if you removed,
so it's testicles and stopped the
distance,
the production of testosterone.
Estrogen preserves bone density,
so you're actually retaining the male
bone density.
There's so many problems with this and
that and that was one of the other
things.
They say,
well,
oh,
the Olympics,
the Olympics allow it.
The Olympics are very ideologically
based.
There's not a whole lot of science to
this.
This transition thing of allowing male
to female athletes to compete in the
Olympics and there's an extreme amount
of corruption in the Olympics as it is
with the IOC being in bed with water,
the world antidoping agency and the way
they handle this Russian scandal,
I mean this Russian scandal that was
highlighted in that fantastic
documentary,
icarus like fucking crazy,
the Olympics or not to be trusted.
That is a gigantic multibillion dollar
business where the athletes get paid
zero money.
It is inherently corrupt from the top
down,
no doubt about it,
so to to call upon them is to see who
should be competing as a woman fuck off.
They're not the experts.
This is.
This is not something that's been
examined and this is coming from someone
who.
One of my jobs is examining and
commentating on fights.
That is a big part of what I do.
I understand fights and I know what it
looks like when a man's beating the shit
out of a woman and that's what it looked
like when this person was fighting
women.
It was.
There was a massive physical advantage,
massive,
not a skill advantage.
What was the,
you mentioned something about the
reaction that you got to that.
What was the trouble you're going to
insult?
People are so mad at me.
I mean it was just so many.
Not only that,
they took my words out of context.
They quoted all these different gender
transition doctors saying that there's
no science behind this and the science
behind it being totally fair and totally
equal.
It's just not and people know it.
Everyone knows live.
They couldn't put Cris Cyborg against
this guy and give him a run for his
money the wrong way class or that's the
other way.
That's the other thing,
and we're dealing with a similar
situation like that in Texas.
I don't know if you know about the girl
who was.
She was born a girl.
She's transitioning to a boy in high
school taking testosterone,
but in Texas they only allow her to
compete as a girl,
so she dominated the Texas state
wrestling championship two years in a
row and it's horrific because she's on
steroids.
She's on testosterone for this kind of
stuff.
Doesn't matter because they're testing
chromosome.
She's a woman.
She was born a woman,
right?
She's born a girl.
So because the fact that she's
transitioning to be a boy,
they don't give a shit.
You're a woman.
You're not going to wrestle against men.
You're a girl.
You're not going to wrestle,
wrestle against boys.
So they have allow her under extreme
protests.
It's terrible.
She wants to compete or he,
I should say,
wants to compete as a boy.
They won't let him.
They say,
no,
you were born a girl.
You have to compete as a girl.
So when he competes everybody booze,
it's off.
It's fucking awful.
I mean,
it's,
it's really devastating question for you
that way around.
If it's female to male transition,
uh,
somebody that used to be a woman that
transitions to a man and wants to
compete with the men,
they don't have an advantage.
They don't know.
They don't allow to disadvantage if they
win in that context.
They've actually done really good.
Yes.
Right spot.
Look,
women can beat men.
Yeah,
I mean it happens all the time.
At Jujitsu.
There's especially in Jujitsu in
particular because it's such a technique
based art,
but it is possible.
There's.
There's also a woman named Jermaine
Duran to me who's a worldclass mixed
martial artists whose multiple time
world champion of fought a man and
knocked him out.
It's a crazy video.
She fostered a real man.
Them with a straight right.
It's.
It is possible for them to win if their
skill level is so far superior that it
overcomes the inherent strength
advantages,
but a woman to male transition would be
at a severe disadvantage against a
natural man.
So would you be in that Texas case?
They clearly have it wrong.
They should.
They should allow him to to compete with
this and would you be.
Whereas I can.
I think all three of us probably
instinctively would resist the notion
that a female,
a male to female athlete competes with
other females because they'd have to
resist that.
Yes.
But would you be for a female to male
athlete competing with men?
Yes,
because I don't think there's.
There's no,
there's no advantage,
but here's the problem and the consent
is sort of running the other direction.
There she is continually putting herself
or he's putting himself in harm's way
knowingly,
and I'm not opposed to a woman fighting
a man if she so chooses like I'm not
opposed to bull riding if you want to.
I'm not lobbying to get bull riding
outlawed,
but if you want to be so fucking stupid
that you climb on top of a 2000 pound
angry animal,
go for it.
Yeah,
maybe you should be able to do whatever
you want.
I think you should be able to jump out a
fairly good aeros airplanes.
You know,
if you want to parachute,
you should be able to risk your life.
Parachuting.
The difference lies in just massive
advantages and that there's a massive
advantage in transitioning from male to
female,
female to male.
Here's the other problem.
Female to male.
You have to take testosterone.
You can't legally take testosterone and
compete.
It's been a giant in mixed martial arts
because for the longest time there was a
loophole and the loophole was
testosterone therapy and they were
allowing testosterone replacement
therapy for male athletes that were
either older or it's.
It was a.
It was a symptom of having pituitary
gland damage,
which comes from head trauma,
which come,
which means really essentially your
career should be over,
your body's not producing hormones
correctly,
and that's a very common issue with
people that have been in war.
People that have been blown up by an
IED,
people that had been hit a lot.
Even soccer players a lot of times show
a diminished levels of testosterone and
growth hormone because of pituitary
gland damage.
So you wouldn't even allow that.
So a female to male would be in a whole
nother problem in combat sports because
it's not legal for you to take
testosterone and compete
right.
Well,
to bring this full circle back to me,
sitting at the pool destroy to destroy
my vacation on twitter.
So how long did you spend working on
this article?
So again,
this was.
This was like,
I must have hated you.
How much was she mad?
Well,
that it was kind of the perfect storm,
but there were,
there were a few things that relieved
the pressure.
One is there was another family from our
schools,
so they're like,
my daughter had a friend,
another couple.
That step that we,
that my wife could socialize with and
having another couple,
they're forced me to sort of put on my
social face at dinner and it.
Well,
yeah,
it's not cheating to look at.
Yeah.
The thing is,
it's actually not that feeling.
It's horrible,
but it's not mean to say it
that way.
He's putting on your social phase.
It actually changes your psychology.
I mean like if you have,
if you,
if you have to drop your problem in
order to be a normal sane person with
people you don't know all that well,
you're actually a happier,
more normal person.
If it had just been me and my wife had
dinner while I'm dealing with this blow
up,
I just,
you know,
it just never would have the cloud
would,
wouldn't have left.
So anyway,
um,
I,
uh,
I was trying,
I was trying not to engage.
And so I didn't want to have to write
anything new to deal with this.
This is what I viewed as just an
egregious attack on,
on my intellectual and moral integrity.
Uh,
and so when I saw this article from
Klein,
um,
I realized I had this email exchange
with him at the end of which I said,
listen,
if you,
if you continue to slander me,
this is the head like a year previously
because there had been released,
I release this so,
so I said,
but I said,
at the end of this exchange,
if you continue to slander me,
and if you misrepresent the reasons why
we didn't do a podcast because we,
we had had talked publicly about maybe
sorting this out on a podcast a year
ago.
But I found the exchange with him by
email.
So in such bad faith,
I found him so evasive and dishonest.
And again,
just plain ideological pingpong as you
said,
and not actually engaging my points that
I said,
listen,
if you,
if you lie about this and you keep
slandering me,
I'm just going to publish his email.
I think the world should see how you
operate as a journalist and as an editor
like he hit,
he had declined to publish a far more
mainstream opinion defending me and
Marie and inbox.
I mean he,
and it was just,
it was,
it was truly slanderous and misleading
everything he's published on this topic
and he has a huge platform by which to
do it.
So,
which I enjoy.
I really like box.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I've,
I've read vox.
We pleasure as well,
but it is,
it once you see how the sausage gets
made on many of these things,
but once,
once your,
the news item,
you can see that there's very little
journalistic scruple in the background
there.
So I,
um,
I was mad I didn't want to have to spend
my time on vacation writing a retort to
this thing,
but I felt like I had to respond.
And again,
this is an illusion.
It was like a sheer confection of
looking at twitter.
And if I hadn't been looking at twitter
I wouldn't have felt they had to
respond.
Um,
and so I responded in the laziest
possible way,
which I just published the email
exchange because it's already written,
I don't have to write anything,
you just hit send essentially.
And of course the rest of the world
didn't know you actually meant to be on
vacation right now.
And so there's no context to them as to
why you were still.
I,
I massively underestimated the amount of
work even my own fans would have to do
to understand why I was so angry and
that email exchange.
So I came off like the angry bastard in
the email exchange and he came off as
this just open minded ready to dialogue
guy.
Whereas if you follow the plot and you
saw what he had published about me and
Ann Marie previously,
this thing that has hit is now on the
hate watch page SPLC.
Uh,
he was being totally disingenuous and
evasive and just,
they didn't match to his article did
they not,
not at all.
And so I just kept getting more tuned up
and,
and so I published this thing not
realizing,
not,
you know,
it was definitely a mistake to publish
the email exchange.
Just pragmatically not,
I don't,
I don't think it was unethical because I
told him I was going to do it in advance
if he kept kept it up.
It was just a,
it was totally counterproductive because
it was his,
he was far more reasonable people,
couldn't he original article.
Well,
it seems like you that do a lot of work
to understand it.
But the thing is he wasn't,
it was sued.
He was,
it was,
it was an appearance of a reason,
but it was,
it was not.
And then we.
So we finally did this podcast.
I'm a year hence,
you know,
this is now my last podcast is now,
two weeks ago.
And uh,
you know,
it was basically as bad as I was
expecting a and I basic,
I feel that I met the person who I
thought I was dealing with in the email
exchange and he was fundamentally
unresponsive to any of my points.
And you know,
as you say,
Joe,
just trying to score political points to
his,
toward his audience.
And the thing is he has.
What's that mean?
There's many,
there are many asymmetries here,
but one crucial one is that he has an
audience that doesn't care about whether
or not he's responsive to the thing that
his,
his opponent or interlocutor just said,
right?
It's,
they're not tracking it by that metric.
They're tracking it by,
are you making the political points that
are ongoing,
that are,
that are massaging that you know,
outraged part of our brains like our go,
do you have your hands on our Amygdala,
you know,
and,
and are you pushing the right buttons?
And so he's talking about racism and
white privilege and I'm granting him all
of that and say,
listen,
let me tell you why that's not relevant
to my concerns.
And what happened here with Marie.
I'm not gonna I'm everything you're
going to say about the history of
lynching.
I'm going to grant you.
Right?
That's not the,
we don't.
There's no daylight between us there.
And,
but the thing is,
I have an audience that is,
that care is massively about following
the logic of a conversation.
If somebody makes a point that is even
close to being good in response to me,
my audience is like,
you know,
okay,
Sam,
what the fuck are you going to say to
that?
And if and if I drop that ball,
I,
I lose massive points.
Right?
Whereas I'm often finding myself in
conversation with people who don't have
to care about those kinds of audiences.
I mean,
that's,
that was the one I had one with this
disease,
the title of the best podcasts ever.
I mean,
he knows his audience does not care
about him,
honestly.
Representing,
in this case,
the doctor
who was that guy even,
I mean at least Ezra Klein,
he could say,
okay,
editor of Vox or whatever.
Where did you even find that?
On twitter?
On twitter.
That's again the twitter growth,
the ruination of podcasts.
Until this day,
I don't even know who this bloke is,
who,
this guy is.
Just some crazy guy.
Me and Nancy.
What did he call me?
It was because at one point he was going
on about me being some form of enabler
of your bigotry and yeah,
well I mean you're an uncle tom native
informant or whatever it is,
but I can show.
I could see this is the.
This is why it's so frustrating because
I have pretty much memorized inside out,
back to front the Islamist ideological
narrative and I could sit here right now
and play that game with you,
that game of ping pong without conceding
anything,
and this is where,
you know,
I feel our conversation went really well
because it was stripped away from all of
that bullshit and we had a genuine
conversation.
It's still to this day very easy for me
to to play the tune of the Islamist and
score those points,
especially because some of what I've
been through school those points and
just get locked in a.
essentially it's ego,
but it's,
it's a,
it's,
it's not an intellectual conversation.
It's a,
it's,
it's a game of you know,
who,
who is,
who is basically checking the right
boxes in their own little confirmation
bias to their own audience and that
doesn't interest me,
but it's frustrating.
You're also,
you're also
the best person on the other side of
that conversation now.
So there's a series of videos on
Youtube,
I think it's called Merry Christmas,
Mr.
That's right.
And so on youtube you can watch him
pitted it against people who are playing
this game,
you know,
Islamists and jihadists of various sorts
in a.
and that he,
Majid is,
is meeting them on your interview show
is mostly in the UK where they're
pretending to be more benign than they
are.
And that module is,
you know,
finding the question that sort of pulls
back the mask on the theocrat and it's
hilarious.
It's very funny that one video that you
publish on your blog.
I've sent to dozens of my friends that
one video where there's this guy and is
addressing this enormous group of people
and he's talking about is this radical
Islam or Islam?
That was a conference in Norway.
That was just,
I mean,
just straight up in Islamic jihadist
addressing a crowd of seemingly
mainstream Muslims in Norway,
but he,
just by,
by show of hands,
you know,
is it,
are we extremists if we think apostates
should be killed,
it's pretty stunning.
It's an amazing document.
Yeah.
In respect to the way they want to treat
homosexuals apostates,
I mean,
the whole thing is,
is this Islam or is this radical Islam
talking of ideology,
blinkering statistical data,
um,
on the subject of homosexuality.
So in the United Kingdom,
a poll was done last year asking,
so there've been two poles gauging
public Muslim attitudes towards gays.
Uh,
the first asked how many Muslims in the
UK find homosexuality is morally
acceptable and zero percent.
This is by the way,
by professional polling companies,
not just some student that's devised a
poll on twitter.
A professional polling company found
zero percent of British Muslims
responded to a poll saying that they
found homosexuality morally acceptable.
And then a year later,
which now last year,
another poll a was a,
was conducted.
And,
uh,
that was a,
an ICM poll asking where the British
Muslims,
how many British Muslims believe that
homosexuality should be criminalized or
remain legal.
And,
uh,
I think it was roughly 52 percent,
52 percent if my memory serves me
correctly,
said of British Muslims said that they
would wish for homosexuality to be
criminalized.
And of course,
what does criminalization of
homosexuality mean under shadier and a
traditional Islamic jurisprudence,
we know that it's punished by death.
So these are these,
this is scientific data from gauging
know attitudes,
British Muslim attitudes towards
homosexuality,
but the ideological blinkers will,
will kick in and refuse to see that
truth.
And these aren't Islamists.
Unfortunately,
my dialogue with Sam,
we talk about this,
that there are the Islamists who wants
to,
who actively want to take over a country
and enforce their version of Islam.
Then there's underneath that there's a,
a softer landing of very,
very conservative stroke,
fundamentalist attitudes that
unfortunately have become widespread.
And here is an example of that is that
is being gauged by scientific polling
methodology that tells us there's a
problem.
And unfortunately,
if one were to speak in this way,
especially in Europe,
one is received by my own political
tribe and that's liberals center left
and further,
one is a met with denial and called a
bigot simply for relaying these facts.
A quarter of British Muslims when asked
about the massacre at the Charlie Hebdo
offices in Paris a quarter said that
those attacks are justifiable.
They sympathize with the attackers as
opposed to the victims who were the
staff at the Charlie Hebdo offices.
So this is what led you to be put on the
southern Harvard speaking in these
terms.
And,
and unfortunately it's reporting polling
data.
And what it does for me is to say this
is why it's so important to address
these issues,
to have these conversations,
to try and empower those Muslim voices
that are seeking to challenge this sort
of,
these sorts of attitudes and,
and carve out a space.
And if,
if,
if one can do that with Catholicism in
Europe and,
and go through a reformation and end up
with an enlightenment and end up with
secularism in the West.
Um,
what I often say is American liberals
are very happy,
challenging their own Bible belt and yet
we have a Koran belt within our
communities and if I'm attempting to
replicate the equivalent of challenging
the Bible belt within Muslim
communities,
it means addressing these issues and yet
they grant to themselves the right to
challenge the Bible belt within America.
And yet if we were to challenge what I
call the Koran belt in Europe were
suddenly called bigots.
Islamophobes is this,
is this static has been moving.
Has it been adjusting and changing?
Is there any sort of a recognition that
there's an issue with this?
So you know,
the emergence of Isis really did bring
it to the fore and it really did quiet
and some of the voices.
It also did increase the hysteria from
the far left because they began
panicking thinking,
actually we're going to lose this
debate.
And that's where I noticed their
labeling became even stronger.
But the emergence of Isis did wake up a
lot of people to,
to the challenges we're facing here.
Because so many European born and raised
Muslims went over to join isis.
And of course,
think about it in this sense,
the most infamous notorious execution
sell that I think were erroneously
called the jihadi beetles in the press
because actually it really does,
it's an insult to the Beatles,
but it was a diminishes the true horror
of these guys,
you know,
they call him jihadi John and,
but the isis executioners basically that
entire cell of the media,
face of ics execution cell were all
British Muslims.
And that should tell you something that
we've got the worst terrorist group
educator.
I mean,
the thing is at university graduate,
like every variable that the far left
wants to marshal to explain this
phenomenon,
like lack of educational opportunity,
lack of economic opportunity,
lack of social integration,
mental illness.
Uh,
you,
you can,
you find people
who had massive opportunity.
I mean,
it's a bit like you were,
you weren't a jihadist,
but you are an Islamist.
But let me,
you're a person who can basically play
in a game.
He wanted me here.
You got to get his.
He's,
he's,
he's somebody who backed to the
superman.
He can run,
he can run for political office.
He hasn't been elected yet,
but he,
you know,
he should be.
I mean,
this is the quarterback of the football
team
in this context is a candidate for
recruitment.
We'll think of.
Think of it this way.
We've got the the worst terrorist group
in our lifetime.
It one can reasonably say,
is Isis right though?
The worst terrorist group,
at least in living memory,
is isis and the worst cell nrcs,
the execution cell came from a fully
developed,
for want of a better term,
first world country,
and that was Britain and Mohammed.
I'm was he the leader of that execution.
Sell,
graduated from the University of
Westminster,
was given as a young child was given
political asylum by Britain because his
family were Kuwaiti and they fled the
invasion of Kuwait by Saddam Hussein,
the country that the west liberated and
he turned against that country.
So he had every reason to like Britain.
Britain gave my home,
gave him a actually physically bricks
and mortar house,
gave his family on social costs.
They gave him social housing.
They educated and he graduated from
university and they liberated his
father's country from an aggressor.
And this man turned against this country
that helped him and his family and his
nation.
Was he captured or did he go?
He's dead.
One of them has been captured,
but he's currently being held in Turkey.
It would be fascinating to listen to his
rationale.
Well,
it's not that the other one,
I forgot his name,
but he was just interviewing tim.
Did you don't get a lot out of him.
He was interviewed by female Arab
journalist.
No,
that was.
And so on.
And dismissive character.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he refused to talk about March.
He said,
uh,
you know,
these are accu accusations and
allegations you're making and I will
wait to trial.
In the end,
he kind of cut the interview short.
He seemed a little put out that she was.
Oh yeah,
he did.
So it says,
I'm looking at you now.
Imagine she's the interview and she's
asking me questions and I'm looking at
direction in your direction.
He literally never laid eyes on her and
it was bad nlp.
It's so intense and it's such,
it,
like,
as you say,
radioactive subject to it's,
it's just fascinating to watch white
liberal progressives just scamper away
from this.
But the flip,
the flip side of the Isis thing has been
the refugee crisis which has made,
which has really empowered both extremes
frankly,
that the far left and the far right so
you have the far right.
You are obviously with the wind in their
sails worrying about this influx of
people from the Middle East and,
and you know,
and beyond North Africa,
uh,
and just the change of culture in their
societies and a lot of these concerns
are plausible,
but because only
the far right and a few other decent
people like Douglas Murray will talk
about the plausible concerns.
Uh,
the space has just been vacated.
So you just have the far right,
far,
far right,
populous politics being enabled and then
you have this delusional open borders
left that won't.
Uh,
we talked about the problem that I told
Sam about this,
but it bears repeating.
Um,
I was having a conversation with someone
as an executive at Youtube and I asked
them why someone got a community
guideline strike on their account
because they posted up a video on their
playlist that they enjoyed of Sam Harris
and Douglas Murray engaged in a
conversation.
I'm like,
I go,
why would that get you a community
guideline strike in?
This woman said,
because it's hate speech.
I got a problem with the last name,
Maria.
Apparently Maria Douglas Murray causing
me problems.
Somebody worked.
She was a big executive at Youtube.
She said,
it's hate speech.
And I told her,
I go,
did you listen to it?
you didn't listen to it.
I go,
this is stunning that you would just say
it's hate speech that you just be so
dismissive of it so quickly.
And she talked to me as if I was her
employee.
Like I was not allowed to question her
and she was just going to say what she
said and I was going to shut up.
And it was a fascinating conversation.
I know this is no lie on vacation.
No,
but it was.
I did a podcast with Douglas and
apparently it got flagged.
Someone else put it up on their account
and I got flagged as hate speech and so
strikes you can get your account
removed.
I've
got a phrase for this and I'd been.
I'd been rallying for it on on social
media for a couple of months now and I
call it a a digital blind spot.
There's a cultural bias on social media
where because of,
and it's intellectually lazy because
because social media is essentially a
California and invention,
right,
and we're in the home state of where
most of this came from it.
It's got a very Californian based
worldview which cares a lot about white
supremacy and doesn't care about many
other forms of bigotry that exists out
there in the rest of the world,
which by the way is the majority of the
world.
So on twitter right now,
of course there's A.
Miley Annapolis has been banned.
Tommy Robinson has been burned as in
taking off now twitter is a private
Tommy Robinson.
He's the former leader of the British
English Defense League,
which was at one time Europe's largest
anti Muslim street protest group.
I helped him leave that organization is
still what many views I completely
disagree with,
but nevertheless he doesn't support or
nor advocate for terrorism.
Why was he removed?
Well,
so twitter,
twitter is a private company.
It can choose to remove whoever it wants
for whatever reason,
and we'll judge it for his
inconsistencies.
But he was ostensibly removed for hate
speech,
as was minor Eunapolis.
Now,
the point being that still till this day
and before people misquote me and
completely say that I'm now defending
hate speech and,
and it's a and their right to speak with
hateful views on twitter.
This is my actual point that til this
day did you know that Hezbollah,
which is a known and recognized
terrorist organization,
so forget hate speech for a moment,
a terrorist organization that believes
in actually killing civilians and Hamas,
a known and recognized terrorist
organization that believes in bombing
babies on buses as a form of resistance.
They still have accounts on twitter.
Um,
and,
and my point is,
is that this is the,
this is the blind spot that I've flagged
twitter about this on many an occasion.
This is the cultural blind spot.
This is the digital blind spot that the,
the dude sitting in California in
wherever who is monitoring this stuff,
and it's probably more than one person.
They don't give a shit that there's some
brown person in the Gaza Strip that
believes it's okay to kill Jewish
babies.
They don't give a shit because it's a
brown person saying it in the name of
Islam.
What they care about is a nonviolent yet
says stupid things guy because he's
white,
called Tommy Robinson in England or Milo
Yiannopoulos,
saying stuff that they obviously that
touches their sensitivities and it's so
intellectually lazy to flag that
immediately and to borrow it from social
media because you're comfortable with
it.
You recognize white supremacy.
It doesn't take any effort to recognize
it.
You don't have to invest in studying
this stuff to know what white supremacy
is.
It takes a bit of effort to study Brown
peoples ideas that you're unfamiliar
with and recognize.
Here's a terrorist organization that's
freely operating on social media.
I know specifically on twitter,
I've actually pulled up their handles.
I think one of the concerns that twitter
has,
and I think this is a valid concern,
is that when you have people that are
saying hateful things and you have
people that are saying whether it's
white supremacy or whatever,
even if it's stupid,
the problem is there is a rallying cry
of trolls that follow behind them and it
builds up momentum and it gets pretty
stunning and that was what was happening
with Milo and by silencing Milo off
twitter.
They have essentially removed him from
the public discourse.
You don't hear about him anymore because
of this because of these things,
but imagine what that does in Arabic
with the terrorist groups.
Everything you've just said,
by the way I agree with and multiply
that for groups that have infrastructure
in multiple countries with actual
organizational hierarchies and plan
means of distributing,
distributing their ideas across entire
populations,
physically fighting in wars right now
such as Hezbollah and Syria,
killing Sunni Muslim rebels,
you know,
and so imagine that and the and the way
you are able to rally a mob in Pakistan
on blast,
for me as an example,
all it takes for some personal and
social media to accuse and other
personal blast for me and they're
probably going to get killed the very
next day and it happens all the time.
But,
but because these Californian based
social media companies are unaware of,
of the,
of the cultural implications of those
sorts of organizations and groups and
listed terrorist groups.
Mind you,
they are this completely.
No,
no barring on any of their activity.
There's also the same thing that you
have with youtube and with a lot of
these other social media organizations
and companies is they don't have to
respond or give you any reasons.
They can say it violates
our terms,
but what are those terms?
Those terms aren't even listed.
It will be vague,
like no hate speech.
Okay.
Well what's hate speech?
Like what do you say?
Like what is.
What are you,
what is your clear policy?
What are your guidelines?
How does someone avoid violating your
guidelines?
They don't say,
and how is the president of the United
States not nonviolent?
Violating those demonetization is
another way that they do it.
They'll remove the ability to put
advertising on,
on,
on a conversation that they don't like
and it doesn't have to be like my
conversation with Douglas Murray was
demonic d without any explanation.
None.
Zero.
They don't have to.
Douglas is,
he's talking to this kid.
He's a hundred percent.
Yeah,
but if you listen to our act,
the actual context of our conversation,
there was nothing even remotely remotely
hateful about it.
Yeah.
I mean these are probably the companies
they've got the right to,
to choose what are the policy.
The only thing I would expect from a
private company is show a consistent
policy tools.
These things,
you know,
if you don't like hate speech than Brown
band Brown people who were also
advocating more than just the hate
speech,
but actually preaching volunteerism.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a strange time for this man because
it's also a time where you can
communicate so instantaneously.
It's fantastic in that regard.
You can get ideas out so quickly,
but these hubs of information like where
the information gets distributed are,
are controlled by people that I don't
think ever knew that they were going to
have this sort of responsibility.
I don't think.
I think you're seeing that with
Zuckerberg and these trials were the,
the,
the speeches that he's given in front of
Congress.
Like when you see him on television
talking about it,
you get the sense that this is a guy
that never prepared for this had no idea
this was going to happen,
and then all of a sudden from this
simple social media platform that was
supposed to be friends sharing photos
and just talking about girls not set up
to put women.
There was a lot of that,
you know,
but I've been to,
and what was twitter?
I mean twitter was essentially just,
you know,
uh,
I mean,
do you remember the old days of twitter?
It would be,
you would use your name like is doing
this,
like sam,
Sam Harris,
like Sam Harris is at the movies.
You would say that almost if you were in
a third person that was the original
form that people would use twitter come
after that.
It was weird.
It was a weird way of talking and then
people started just writing what they
thought and it just became and then
became ideology and then it became a
sharing links,
sharing links and interesting articles
is a big part of it.
But this,
to me that's the only good part of it
now.
Like I,
like I've just discovered that and that
was most of my attachment to it.
I mean I genuinely use it to,
as a,
as,
as a curator of newspapers.
I follow interesting people,
they they tweet interesting stuff and I
and I consume it that way,
but noticing what's coming back at me in
the Atlantis.
I put something out,
know a podcast and then I looked to see
it's being received on
twitter and I don't tend to do that in
other forums.
I don't really look at facebook comments
much.
I don't look at Youtube or Youtube
assessable.
Right.
I mean,
so even if they're for you that the
comments are horrible,
why is that?
I don't.
It's been started on the youtube
comment.
Friends.
It's spread everywhere else.
It's very strange but.
So I.
But one thing I found that you can
change your settings and twitter where
you,
you a screen out,
people who don't have a twitter egg
photos,
they don't have a real photo.
You can screen out people who haven't
had their email confirmed and I think I
just did those two things and like 90
percent of the hate went away.
It was amazing.
Like it just,
just doing that just.
It was amazing.
Thank you for that.
You should do that.
Except I'm.
I think it's better to not actually even
look at what's coming back at.
You would have taken it off your phone?
No,
I think so too.
I think looking,
looking at it,
my wife Rachel will be very happy with
that and then she should.
I think she'd probably wish that I did
tweak on it to.
Do you read things and get angry?
I'm,
I don't,
I don't react sometimes.
I like to think I don't react in this
way,
but I mean I can't,
I can't say that because actually
probably I have some times,
but you know,
I get all that same kind of.
It's interesting because I took,
I took a stance on the Syria strikes.
And what was your stance?
Well,
I just think that um,
uh,
especially now in hindsight,
were there no,
no casualties involved at all.
There were only three injuries.
I think we had to take a stance that
succeeded where Obama failed in,
in making sure that red line was
maintained,
that the use of chemical weapons cannot
be tolerated.
Even if it was symbolic even it was
highly symbolic.
I think sometimes symbolism is
important.
So I took that stance and uh,
it got a lot of love on twitter.
Well,
yeah,
of course,
because that's actually,
that's against the grain.
A public opinion at the moment is it was
against the strikes,
so fully acknowledged that when I took
the stance,
but I argued a case and I set the case
out in both on my sky news show.
I have a show,
I'm a cohost on the pledge and also on
my radio show and LBC.
I repeatedly argued for why I think is
important that we don't allow for
chemical weapons and they used to become
militarized in our world.
Um,
and so it was interesting because I
posted the Sky News clip of me sort of
talking to camera about my reasons for
this and the.
And,
and uh,
I have this screen grab of the reaction.
It's actually hilarious.
It's just a puddle of blood.
It is the two extremes.
They actually started fighting with each
other about who's right about there.
So obviously,
look,
here's a clip,
why we must intervene in Syria after
that chemical that blah blah.
The first one is a guy with an actual
swastika Nazi symbol on his profile is,
is wonderful,
and it says,
you know,
at Nordic Scott is is handled Thomas
James,
he says,
Magid wants Britain to intervene in
Syria because Putin and acid are kicking
his isis buddies office's end of story.
Right?
So there's the guys basically saying,
but my real reason for calling for that
is because I'm supporting isis against
the regime.
The guy immediately often responds to
him and it's called [inaudible] and he
says,
what do you want about Nancy Demoss?
Magid is funded by.
Your law is a far right.
Uncle Tom.
So they're fighting with each other.
They actually,
no,
this is a captures that,
but they're arguing with each other over
whether I'm in his camp or his camp.
The far right and the far left,
basically you didn't have the words
publicists in the world or the best one.
So I should take myself out of that
equation.
Let them fight each other.
It would be even better.
Really.
It,
that's the move to set something like
that upset the far right and the far
left against each other.
And you can just sneak away while
they're fighting.
That's how nuts it is.
The twitter kind of horses,
the extremes are,
are um,
I mean they're equally irrational and
the fact that you could be at the
epicenter of,
of each prompt a both of their problems.
Yeah.
That you're,
you're a covert jihadist and you're an
anti Muslim bigot.
It seems like there's more conspiracy
theories in terms of like what someone's
actual motivation for what they're
saying now than ever before to because
it's so easy to express them.
So someone could say,
no,
you know,
he's far right or no,
you're,
you're just trying to support isis like
this.
This is this ability to like find some
nefarious reason for your actions.
But again,
it's reducing one's opinion to the
lowest base,
you know,
dodgy motive as opposed to applying the
principle of charity.
So if joe says something now I can
either sit here and actually think,
no,
I don't trust this guy,
I don't respect him and therefore I'm
going to reduce his opinion to the worst
possible interpretation that he could
possibly mean.
And then use that against him.
Or I could continue to ask what you mean
by that because I'm assuming you're a
good,
decent human being in origin and perhaps
you mean something that I haven't yet
quite grasped.
And then I'll ask you,
clarify your own opinion in your own
words.
And I think it's unfortunate that many
of our conversations today in the far
left is as guilty of it as the far right
and they like to think they're not,
which is part of that righteousness that
blinds them from actually committing
this very same injustice.
They accused the far right of
committing.
And that is,
uh,
it's the same bigotry in a mirror image,
I call it the bigotry of low
expectations.
The low expectations they have that
Muslims are somehow unable to adhere to
common,
decent liberal,
secular democratic values.
And so it's actually a plaguing our
conversations if only we were able to
strip away our ideological baggage in
entering conversations and,
and allow for,
you know,
that honest,
honest conversation.
But of course we say that and then you
try to replicate our success in a number
of occasions and found yourself
incredibly frustrated while you are one
more time.
Well,
it's unfortunate.
I found the one reasonable person to
have a fight with.
Well,
it just seems like this is a side effect
of this increased ability to communicate
and that there's so much noise and
there's so much going on.
I mean,
it's just the most fantastic time for
the distribution of information.
There's never been a time where it's so
easy to distribute information in human
history.
It's really crazy.
But I don't think we know what to do
with it.
And I think when you deal with people
who have such rigid ideologies and they
this incredibly
easy ability to express these
ideologies,
there's just so much clashing.
It was just so much,
so much noise and nonsense.
And when someone says something that
they know that they don't have to back
up with facts because they know that
they're there,
people were on their position,
will support it.
You say the right keywords,
you know,
white privilege,
whatever you want to say.
And then boom,
you're going to get a whole slew of
people like those two people in your,
your mentions battling it out with each
other.
You're just like kind of picking fights
and starting these little fires and
letting other people to
go to war.
You know what I think we've done,
and it's again,
the advent of social media is that we
are speaking with my friend mark about
this and we've democratized truth and
when you democratize truth in that way,
the earlier thing you mentioned about
sports,
combat sports and your expertise in
their field.
If I had come back at you and spoke at
you with as much authority as you claim
in your expertise with having absolutely
no history in that expertise whatsoever
and assumed that I have as equal right
to an unresearched claim to truth in my
opinion,
as you do and who has a lifetime of
experience in that field.
There in lies a problem that I'm
aggregating to myself.
This notion,
this,
this kind of belief that my opinion
though,
I of course have an equally legal right
to express it,
but it doesn't mean it carries the same
weight as your opinion when it comes to
combat sports and it shouldn't.
Unfortunately,
I think what's happened with the advent
and worse still you could add your
expressing that opinion as a person of
color as somehow therefore it's an
criticizable by you because it's his
truth.
Otherwise you are racist and it's Mike.
That's the key word that it's my truth
and so the problem with that is when you
relativized truth in that way,
is that then I can speak to you on on an
equal footing about combat sports,
which only a mad person who hasn't had
that history in comments.
What would think would aggregate to
themselves,
right?
To do so,
but social media I think has allowed for
that to happen.
I gave a Ted talk in about,
I think it was roughly 2011 about the
dangers of this happening in social
media,
dividing us all,
but I'd say now that if I were to pitch
that Ted talk today,
I did it at Ted Global.
If I were to pitch that Ted talk today,
it wouldn't be accepted because it's not
something new now.
It's now people know that how social
media is has divided us,
but back then it was new and innovative
enough as an idea for Ted global to say
we want you to speak about this on and
it's still up online,
but if people watched it today,
they think,
how on earth did that become a Ted talk?
Because there was this heady day back
in,
you know,
five,
six,
seven years ago,
this kind of hope filled moment where
everyone thought Google,
facebook and twitter and generally
social media and also tech companies
were like the good guys that these
companies weren't actually companies
that they were on our side against the
corporate world and it turns out.
I think we've just hit this moment.
You mentioned Zuckerberg.
We,
I think we've culturally come to this
moment now where think symbolized by his
testimony at Congress
that those,
that,
that honeymoon period is over,
people now view him,
I think quite firmly and squarely as a
ceo of a very rich company as opposed to
a guy in my club that I'm friends with
WHO's on my side against the world,
you know,
and that's how,
Google used to have that slogan,
don't do evil jumbly they still have it.
I mean the problem is the incentives are
all wrong and so actually I was just at
Ted and will they give you a sense of
how far the rod has spread here?
So I was,
I found myself at a dinner sitting next
to a neuroscientist who thought that
this Ezra Klein thing followed me around
at Ted and it's because many people have
listened to the podcast and he thought
Charles Murray should have been
physically attacked at Middlebury.
This is a neuro as a neuroscientist.
Academic was impeccable person.
Otherwise.
I mean,
I think he was,
after we wound up having to fight a or a
dinner over it,
I think he was somewhat chagrined by
having expressed that opinion,
but I mean,
that's how,
how emotionally hijacked people are by
this issue and uh,
but it's a,
um,
that's incredible.
It was just.
Yeah,
it was the other thing that's new.
This is the other thing that it's new.
The left advocating for violence.
This is very new.
Yeah.
I mean,
I always felt like the left was a
nonviolent.
The whole idea behind being progressive,
like nonviolence was,
was a genuine aspect of that.
And free speech to things.
Yeah.
Those are two things that have been sort
of stopped.
That free speech is fine as long as
you're not saying speech that I disagree
with and nonviolence.
Sure.
In less we need to use violence,
which is in the people that are saying
it.
Like if you watch these anti for people
like Jesus Christ,
the most incompetent,
violent people you've ever seen in your
life.
It depends.
Your sensibility.
Does that ever make it funny?
You guys are terrible at it.
There's videos of these guys practicing,
there's videos of Antifa they had got
together and decided to train and
prepare for violence and so they're
doing these martial arts classes.
They have people teach them like holy
shit,
like at the average high school kid
could fuck you guys up.
Like this is the most ridiculous thing
I've ever seen in my life,
but it's almost like they're.
They realize that there's not that much
danger in what they're doing and they
can kind of play with danger.
They can play with violence.
They can put the masks on their,
you know,
they're not in Israel.
They're out at the Gaza Strip.
Are there a bunch of counts as a guy.
There's a guy who went to my old
university I graduated from,
so asked before I did my masters at the
NSC,
so as has been embroiled in a strike at
the moment as the student's union has
been supporting professors who were on
strike and it's over the pension and
pension rights in refused government
refusing to raise their pension rights
and whatever,
and some of the students came out and
strike,
fall up students defending the
professors and they put,
they put forward a ring preventing from
attending
their classes and,
and,
and a,
a female black lecturer wanted to cross
the strike lines to go into teach her
students a white male public school
educated,
very,
very middleclass protester far left,
physically attacked her.
He physically attacked a female black
professor.
So gone is suddenly gone.
Is The white privilege gone?
Is the male attacking a female?
You know,
gone is all of that non violence.
All the above.
The name of ideology he legitimized and
allowed himself to attack a black
female,
by the way.
Oh.
And she was also Muslim,
so she,
when she went into the prep,
he would've had the right Sheila.
She actually said that in her interview
she said,
I'm a black Muslim female and this white
kid is just a tip for wanting to teach
my class.
This is crazy.
This is a crazy world we're in,
man.
This is.
Do you.
Are you optimistic about the future?
Yeah,
I say that because it's going to take a
lifetime's work and I don't think that
in our lifetime much is gonna Change.
I think maybe for the next generation.
What is the picture of how do you
conceive of your job at the moment and,
and what,
uh,
what is the status quo?
For instance,
isis or the Islamic state is sort of
fading from most people's memory now.
I mean,
even mine,
I'm A.
I'm spending much less time thinking
about it because it seems to visit.
So let me tell you a story
so I can answer this question with a
story.
So radical,
which is my autobiography,
has a US publication,
right?
I'm in the UK.
It's random house penguin.
It's published by the biggest publishing
house.
When I came to publishing theU ,
s I approached publishing houses,
but it was after bin Laden was killed
and so when we approached 10,
20,
whatever,
publishing houses the problem solve,
they all said no.
They said the problem solved.
They said,
we think,
you know,
we wish you'd come to us five years
earlier,
but problem solve now there's not a
problem anymore.
And uh,
and a bit like what you mentioned is
sort of your expertise.
And,
and I,
I have been consumed by this subject all
my life and there are a few people on
this planet that I would take seriously
on this subject.
I'm outside especially of Quilliam.
And there are other organizations,
they have some really good people,
but I know them all and we regularly
speak.
So I would say it's all of these
publishing houses.
I can assure you 100 percent this
problem not only has not been solved is
going to come back around in a far west
way than you can ever have imagined.
This is before isis came along.
None of them believe me.
Of course.
What then happened,
my cook book eventually got published by
some very small publishing house in the
US and has done quite well for them,
but the point of the story was this.
Isis came around and people were
suddenly like,
oh my God,
where did this come from?
Of course,
those of us who had been monitoring the
situation knew this was going to come
back around very,
very heavy.
Now that isis has been pushed back,
and this is where this story is sort of
the point of the story is we've got to
resist the temptation to believe the
problem has been solved because the the
organization known as Isis,
which isn't a bureaucracy has been
fought back,
but the ideology upon which that
organization was built is still very
much alive and it's still strong.
What al Qaeda did while the whole world
was focused on Isis was exploited,
that opportunity to rebuild and regroup
and they've been a rebuilding and Syria.
Now they are stronger than they have
ever been,
even under binladin because for the
first time in the history of that
organization,
they are firmly embedded within the
Syrian population as a genuinely kind of
viewed by the people that they were
fighting on behalf of as a grassroots
resistance organization.
Whereas before that they were seen as a
terrorist group that was like a,
just like a vanguard.
They've embedded themselves in the
Syrian population,
in the Yemeni civil war.
They've embedded themselves in north
Africa,
east Africa and in Pakistan,
and they are resurgent and they are
grooming Hamza bin Laden,
who has been not in some and the
grooming infant leadership and a time
will come maybe in a couple of months,
maybe in a couple of years where they
announced Hamza bin Ladin as a new
leader of al Qaeda currently at Simon's
Zawahari.
When they do that,
once they're grooming has been complete
and assuming Hamza isn't killed,
uh,
up until then,
all of the fragments of what remains of
Isis will probably rejoin all kind of
under Hamza bin Laden.
And you'll have a stronger than ever
before on Kaleida organization.
And we've got to,
we've got to remember that we never
expected isis to emerge.
Emergent,
kind of.
We'll come back with a vengeance.
It.
What is the,
the politics between the remnants of
Isis,
isis and al Qaeda.
Well,
how has it been hard in succession to
the leadership solves that problem of
the.
Because the isis guys were originally
all kind of Isis was al Qaeda in Syria
and they broke away after bin Laden died
because they didn't.
They had pledged allegiance to bin Ladin
and the new leader of al Qaeda,
Ayman Suare is by all accounts,
a rather uncharismatic.
And you know,
he's a,
he's a pediatrician.
He's not really a kind of bin Laden.
Had the pediatrician.
Yeah,
he's a pro.
He's Egyptian.
He's an Egyptian pediatrician from a
very well off Egyptian family by the
way.
I think his grandfather was the Egyptian
ambassador to the UN pharmacists and
it's been loud and clearly had the
charisma,
the wealth,
the presence,
the looks.
He had all of it.
That doesn't as worries,
you know,
competitive bin Ladin.
It does.
It doesn't say if the guys that broke
away from all kind of centers a watery,
the current leader,
we pledged allegiance to be lighting,
we owe you nothing.
You're not our Amir,
our leader.
If Hamza bin Ladin comes back in as the
leader of all kind of,
it solves that problem because of those
remnants of Isis have a loyalty to the
bin Ladin Name and had been in family
and they remember what they consider
their glory days fighting under on the
bin Laden.
That's not nice to hear.
That's no good.
No,
no.
The problem has not gone away.
I can tell you that the problem and the
problem is the ideology and it will not
be dealt with until we deal with this
ideology and it's why it's so dangerous
to.
You know,
there was this awful term that I railed
against.
It was so frustrating to see.
Under Obama's presidency,
the US State Department officially
adopted as their name for challenging
this problem.
They adopted the term al Qaeda inspired
extremism.
Of course it isn't.
It isn't al Qaeda,
that it inspired extremism.
It's extremism that inspired al Qaeda
and it's for the purposes of political
correctness,
you adopt this term and the State
Department officially that we're
fighting across the world.
We are fighting al Qaeda inspired
extremism.
My former organization,
his caliphate espousing organization
that believes in their ideal caliphate
that gays should be killed,
a doctorate,
she should be stoned to death.
They were there before all Kinda and
this ideology has been there before on
cod.
Okada was one of a long line of groups
that came as a result of the Islamist
ideology and we've got to start focusing
on the ideology itself,
not the physical groups that spring up
from it because they can change their
name.
As you point out,
there is a another layer to the ideology
that is all that is even more well
subscribed,
that present social and political
problems.
So for this one,
as you said,
there are conservative Muslims who don't
support al Qaeda.
They're not jihadists.
They they can.
They would honestly say bin Ladin
doesn't represent my brand of Islam,
but these are still people who will,
who will say that homosexuals should be
killed.
So,
so there,
there's the apparent allies against
extremism can still be people with so
with religiously mandated social
attitudes that just cannot be
assimilated in cosmopolitan societies.
Uh,
so people who are worse,
worse than worse than Al Qaeda inspired
extremism.
There's just this notion that on the
left,
and,
and this was,
this came out of Obama's mouth and it
came out of Clinton's mouth and it's
largely why she's wasn't president.
Uh,
it's not,
it's just generic extremism,
right?
So that,
like in the same sentence that you have
to worry about the caliphate.
You have to talk about,
uh,
abortion doctors being killed in the US
once every year,
15 years.
So you read,
of course,
you remember because President Obama
refused to use the word Islamist
extremism.
Of course trump has the other problem.
He thinks that like rumpelstiltskin by
repeating it enough,
you've solved the problem.
But,
but actually one of the elements in
which he was correctly critical of Obama
was an,
I was at the time vocally critical of
Obama's reluctance to use the word
Islamist extremism.
And we've got no problem when we talk
about,
you know,
uh,
when we talk about white supremacist
ideology,
we don't mean that all white people are
supremacists,
you know,
what we were doing here is it's actually
attributing precisely specifically what
the ideology is and believes in white
supremacy and likewise Islamist,
you know,
it's important.
So we can that ideology,
I'm still while not calling it Islam,
right?
So we're still giving a bit of a leeway
there for everybody else,
all the other Muslims,
but to call it Islamic extremism,
Mr.
recognize that it's an offshoot of
Islam.
It's a manifestation,
extreme or otherwise obvious lamb.
And thereby we are acknowledging that
it's justification's are in Islamic
scripture as well as of course,
a multiplicity of other calls,
these grievances and what have you.
But we cannot ignore that.
It also rests on justifications that are
derived from the Islamic scripture.
I mean,
I can cite for the Arabic that tells you
in the Koran itself to cut the hand of
the thief or to lash the adulterer.
Um,
you know,
these are all Heidi for the saying of
the prophet that says,
kill the person that changes their
religion.
This is scripture.
And so of course there are other factors
involved as well,
but one of the factors that gives rise
to this,
uh,
is the unreformed scripture that these
extremist site.
And so we have to acknowledge that Islam
has a role to play.
I often say that,
you know,
because again,
under the Obama presidency,
it was frustrating that the common
refrain was to say that Islam,
this has nothing to do with Islam.
This is absurd.
Is arguing that the Spanish inquisition
had nothing to do with Catholicism.
He went even further.
One point,
didn't he at one point say that not only
does this have nothing to do with his
mom,
this has less to do with Islam than any
other related intimately that if it was
just he bent over backwards.
It's nice saying the crusades have
nothing to do with Christianity.
Gentlemen,
unfortunately.
Have to wrap this up.
I really appreciate you guys coming on.
It was a real pleasure to meet you and
your book.
It's the book is Islam and the future of
tolerance and actually were the one
thing we do have to announce is we're
going to Sydney and Auckland.
Yeah.
Two of us and Douglas Murray and both
Weinstein brothers were we're going to
wreck those towns.
Oh my goodness.
We're going to have you doing live
podcasts a day long conference generic.
No,
but it'd be great to get both of them
together that rarely.
Those guys are awesome.
I'm really grateful to meet both of them
and you as well.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.